hablamos ahora de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france 24 y mañana en
miércoles rosa pérez más de conmigo en
el estudio rosa vamos a abrir abrir esta
revista de prensa con una noticia
lamentable que sucedió esta mañana y que
ya circula por todos los medios de
comunicación y es la muerte de esta
periodista del medio al yazira era
estadounidense palestina vamos a dar
entonces una mirada a lo que está
ocurriendo sobre este caso en diferentes
medios de comunicación rosa y por
supuesto empezamos por al yazira buenos
días raúl exactamente no como decías
después de unas horas de este asesinato
ya la noticia está en medios de
comunicación de alrededor del mundo eso
sí la forma de cubrirlo es distinta
depende de donde pongamos el foco no es
que siempre que ocurren cosas así sobre
todo en los territorios palestinos pues
en la fort la cobertura que dan los
medios internacionales es ya un tema en
sí pero si te parece empezamos por al
yazira como bien decías es el medio
donde trabajaba sin agua clair quién
acusa directamente a las fuerzas
israelís del asesinato de su periodista
sin presunciones ni suposiciones no al
yazira dice las fuerzas israelís
maldad mataron dispararon mortalmente a
la periodista de al yazira es irina
bucle en cisjordania ocupada según
confirmó el ministerio palestino de
salud también aseguran que fue un
asesinato a sangre fría dicen es un
asesinato flagrante que viola las leyes
y normas internacionales las fuerzas de
ocupación israelí asesinaron a sangre
fría a la corresponsal de al yazira en
palestina y al yazira mismo dedica
muchas piezas no un poco a la figura de
esta periodista asesinada esta mañana
ahora de cisjordania pero entre ellas
hay una especie de obituario donde
repasan su vida y su carrera recuerdan
nació en jerusalén tenía 51 años
trabajaba en al yazira desde
1997 es decir ya hacía 25 años no que
trabajaba con esta cadena basada en
qatar y murió de un disparo en la a
pesar de llevar chaleco y el casco para
protegerse de potenciales balas por otro
lado no sé si estamos viendo aquí bueno
si algunas de las piezas hay una galería
de fotografías donde se ve entre otras
cosas su cuerpo cubierto ya en la
bandera palestina su cuerpo sin vida
también vemos una imagen del periodista
elisa moody quien también resultó herido
en el mismo contexto pero está estable
en el hospital informan también que el
funeral seguramente tendrá lugar mañana
jueves en jerusalén después de la
autopsia y también vemos una imagen de
wally tal omar y el jefe de la oficina
de al yazira en palestina con el chaleco
antibalas de la periodista agua cree y
entre otras cosas pues se citan los
recuerdos que tienen sus seres queridos
de la periodista por ejemplo uno sabe
que dicen shirín abogada clare era una
periodista valiente y amable con una
risa contagiosa consagrada a contar las
historias cotidianas de los palestinos
hasta los grandes eventos como las
intifadas o las guerras por otro lado
raúl también destacan el último mensaje
que mandó el sur y nawa clegg a la
central de al yazira
en este mensaje demandado las 6 30 de la
mañana
su obra de cisjordania decía las fuerzas
de ocupación asaltan henning y asedian
una casa en el barrio de yadría estoy de
camino les traeré noticias tan pronto
como la imagen se aclare y al ser sidra
dice pues no podíamos saber que esta
noticia sería su martirio en todo caso
lamentable la muerte de un trabajador de
la prensa haciendo su labor que es
precisamente como la hacemos todas las
mañanas aquí en directo américa es
informar el derecho de la información
que tiene todas las personas rosa vamos
a ver ahora como lo resaltan los medios
de la zona hablamos de wafa harry reid
de medir y site exactamente empezamos
por el middle east hay que y lo que
hemos querido seleccionar un poco de los
distintos medios es sobre todo las citas
de periodistas que se encontraban en el
lugar de los hechos no porque como
decías es lo que está generando un poco
de controversia alrededor de cómo
explicar la autoría de este asesinato
en primer lugar middle east hay cita a
una de sus colaboradoras chata en asia
que explica que eran seis periodistas en
el momento de los hechos y que estaban
juntos cuando los francotiradores
empezaron a disparar en la entrada
principal del campo de refugiados de
jenín y que habían elegido esa zona que
estaban precisamente ahí porque no es
una zona donde hubiera enfrentamientos
no así como dice el gobierno israelí que
atribuye la matanza pues a combatientes
palestinos esta periodista asegura que
no que allí no hay donde cubrirse que
por eso mismo estaban los periodistas en
esa zona alejados pues de los tiroteos
por otro lado hemos querido seleccionar
ha aretz y wafa que lo que hacen es pues
resaltar un poco las versiones bueno las
reacciones internacionales porque como
bien decías se orinaba clegg era
ciudadana estadounidense también y el
embajador de eeuu en israel ha pedido ya
investigar su muerte y también la herida
de alisa modif
desde el hospital declaró estábamos allí
para cubrir los eventos en el campamento
de henning de repente los israelís
abrieron fuego contra nosotros no nos
pidieron no nos pidieron que nos
fuéramos o nos detuviéramos la primera
bala me alcanzó a mí y la segunda a
schering no había combatientes de la
resistencia palestina a nuestro
alrededor si no no hubiéramos estado
allí algo que confirma también un
periodista de afp y wafa también agencia
palestina de noticias destaca que la
unión europea pide también una
investigación vamos con los medios
occidentales rosa el país the guardian
new york times' exactamente el país
entre otras cosas explica que esta bala
alcanzó a la periodista justo debajo de
la oreja en la parte que no estaba
cubierta pues por el casco y que parecía
que le hubieran apuntado allí digamos
voluntariamente y que esta muerte ocurre
un año después de la destrucción de las
oficinas de al yazira en gaza por un
ataque aéreo israelí por otro lado the
gardian pues entre otras cosas señala
también una declaración de un periodista
que estaba también en el lugar de los
hechos y dice incluso después de que
ella cayera al suelo el fuego no se
detuvo y ninguno de nosotros pudo
alcanzarla éramos un grupo todos
vestidos con equipamiento de prensa y
shirín e incluso llevaba casco así que
obvio que quien le disparó pretendía
impactar en una parte expuesta de su
cuerpo también the gardian señala que la
federación internacional de periodistas
llevó ante la corte penal internacional
una denuncia de ataques sistemáticos de
israel contra periodistas el pasado mes
de abril y señala este medio británico
que al menos 144 periodistas palestinos
han sido heridos por las fuerzas
israelíes en los territorios palestinos
franja de gastar de gaza jerusalén este
cisjordania y por último el 'new york
times' a pues he elegido un titular que
ha sido controvertido porque dice matan
a una periodista de al yazira durante
enfrentamientos en cisjordania y ahí
hemos querido señalar el tuits de la
productora de al yazira lina alza fan
que ha criticado este titular porque
dice esto es una mentira descarada y no
hubo enfrentamientos y otros periodistas
presentes dijeron que no había presencia
de combatientes palestinos raúl rosa
pues sí todo obviamente un tema con el
asesinato de esta periodista que
seguramente se va a esclarecer en los
próximas días y por supuesto le haremos
seguimiento aquí en directo américa y
entrevista de prensa rosa gracias por
toda la información nos vemos mañana con
más pasamos a saludar a nuestra primera
invitada del día